this is for sure sausage houses brownie
what's up I'm Nadia and I got sent these
really cool ice cream flavors from cool
house and I'm gonna have my fast food
love being coworkers do a blind taste
test and see if they can guess what
flavor it is that they're eating
I'm Jessica I'm Kailyn my favorite fast
food shaker my favorite fast food I
think is I'm a huge advocate for
McDonald's guys I'm just gonna be honest
I was gonna say in and out but I can't
hide it I'm David I'm Jake I rock with
McDonald's breakfast stuff I'll try to
get like del Taco or something I like
Wendy's I like the junior bacon
cheeseburger at Wendy's it's great more
like a chick-fil-a you know I have no
idea what we're gonna about to eat it's
an ice cream it probably is gonna be
like tablecloth flavor or like wet dog
just kind of think with the opposite of
what we want I've had experiences with
you before can I smell it like a caramel
egg flavor that's enjoyable that's for
sure frosty thanks right it is look at
this little expects or some sort of
cereal you know
No what is it it's oh the disrespect the
ice cream version of like chicken and
waffles basically yeah I think I should
be grossed out but it's not she just
said that for the camera because it's
not I see the care in the back is
actually some salted caramel pretzel
that I love this is such a treat this is
fire when I do get a chewy bite though
now that I know it's chicken skin that's
for sure you guys know this is gonna be
foul this looks like a potato chip let
me guess okay cookie dough no that man
cookie dough french fry and burger
chocolate-covered barbecued chicken eyes
okay potato skin right there I know uh
some more I will know that I know it's
safe and you'll be the meanest trick
they said Oh with the name chicken fries
and then it's like two dogs a little
frog are right there this is delicious
this is like a nice bite and the soft
ice test this one out
oh it smells like chocolate sausage is
brownie that's pretty good mm-hmm those
flavor that's a good idea yet clear to
me is very soon synonym mini that that's
whatever that seminary cinnamon lemon in
cinnamon anemone cinnamony
[Music]
I'm not my person was pretty good I
think my favorite changes up to knowing
yeah
it was blind Oliver they wouldn't tell
me my preferred line but now I'm like
this one because it's normal
now I'm really want to try ice cream
with my fried chicken
[Music]